the White House says it will brief a
group of Democratic lawmakers this
morning on allegations that Russia paid
bounties to kill US troops in
Afghanistan President Trump says he was
told nothing about those intelligence
reports before the information came out
last week published reports say
officials provided a written briefing to
the president earlier this year that
laid out the intelligence on the alleged
bounties Ben Tracy is at the White House
Ben what's the administration saying
well good morning the White House press
secretary says that the president has
never been personally briefed on this
intelligence but she did not answer the
question as to whether or not this
information was ever in his classified
Daily Brief and he just never read it
how can you run an administration where
something this important is not brought
to your level
Democrats accused President Trump of
having a blind spot on Russia despite
what Donald Trump may think Russia is
not a friend they are a foe even some
Republicans like lawmakers Liz Cheney
and Mac Thornberry who were briefed
Monday say they remain concerned about
Russian activity in Afghanistan
including reports that they have
targeted US forces there is no consensus
within the intelligence community on
these allegations but at a briefing
Monday the White House press secretary
repeated herself a half dozen times no
consensus no consensus not a consensus
saying US intelligence agencies do not
agree on whether Russia paid bounties to
Taliban linked fighters to kill American
troops
it would not be elevated to the
president until it was verified that
echos the president who claims Intel did
not find this info credible and
therefore did not report it to me but
CBS News has learned the CIA believed
the allegations to be true while the
National Security Agency questioned them
and the president's national security
aides discussed it it's still not clear
why President Trump would have been
completely unaware counterterrorism
expert Hill Seth Jones that definitely
should have reached the president if it
was deemed credible
and by credible you know I mean ideally
more than one source in a rare move the
CIA director the Director of National
Intelligence and the National Security
Advisor all released statements last
night blasting the leaking of classified
information but they did not deny these
reports now the Director of National
Intelligence John Ratcliffe he says the
fact that these allegations about Russia
are now public will make it harder to
find out what actually happened Tony
still a lot of questions there Ben Tracy
Fores Ben thank you very much